coming Gillies there are more breaking
news for you uh this afternoon this time
concerning Northern Ireland we're
hearing that MI5 has increased the
threat to Northern Ireland from Northern
Ireland related terrorism from
substantial meaning an attack is likely
to severe which means that an attack is
very likely now normal secretary Chris
Heaton Harris has issued a statement
saying the public should remain Vigilant
but not be alarmed and continue to
report any concerns they have to the
Police Service of Northern Ireland he
goes on to say in recent months we've
seen an increase in levels of activity
relating to Northern Ireland's terrorism
which has targeted police officers
serving their communities and also put
at risk the lives of children and other
members of the public these attacks have
no support as demonstrated by the
reaction to the abhorrent attempted
murder you're a member of DCI Caldwell I
paid tribute to the tremendous of the
Police Service of Northern Ireland and
security partners and the determination
and resilience of the Northern Ireland
people who are making all mileage a
safer place to live and work so the
breaking news that MI5 has increased the
threat to Northern Ireland from Northern
Ireland related terrorism from
substantial to severe we'll be speaking
to our correspondent in Belfast a little
later on in the program